considera que el 15 por ciento de 1750
estudiantes de cierta escuela sufrieron
niveles extremos de estrés durante el
mes pasado los miembros de un periódico
estudiantil no conocen estos datos pero
se interesan en el tema así que deciden
realizar una encuesta a una muestra
aleatoria de 160 estudiantes preguntando
si ellos sufrieron niveles extremos de
estrés durante el mes pasado más tarde
obtuvieron que el 10 por ciento de la
muestra respondía que sí a la pregunta
suponiendo que la proporción correcta es
del 15% lo cual es cierto es justo lo
que nos dicen acá arriba consideran que
el 15% de 1.750 estudiantes de cierta
escuela sufrieron niveles extremos de
estrés durante el mes pasado así que
déjenme escribirlo p es igual a 0.15
cuál es la probabilidad aproximada de
que más del 10% de los alumnos de la
muestra reporte que ellos sufrieron
niveles extremos extra
durante el mes pasado pausa el vídeo e
intente encontrar la respuesta bueno la
forma en la que vamos a resolverlo es
pensar en la distribución muestral de
las proporciones déjame escribirlo e
intentar preguntarnos si esta
distribución es aproximadamente una
distribución normal y si lo es entonces
podemos usar su media y su desviación
estándar y crear una distribución normal
que tenga la misma media y desviación
estándar a fin de que obtengamos la
probabilidad que nos preguntan así que
primero pensemos en esta parte como
decidimos si es cierto bueno teníamos
una regla básica que nos decía que si al
multiplicar el tamaño de la muestra por
la proporción de la población y esto es
mayor o igual a 10
y además si al multiplicar el tamaño de
la muestra por 1
p y que esto también sea mayor o igual a
10 si ambas cosas se cumplen la regla
básica nos dice que podemos aproximar la
distribución a una distribución normal
así que en este caso los miembros de un
periódico estudiantil le preguntan a 160
estudiantes así que en el tamaño de la
muestra es 160 estudiantes y si a esto
lo multiplicó por la verdad de la
proporción de la población que es 0.15
ok esto tiene que ser mayor o igual a 10
y realmente lo es bueno veamos 15 % de
160 es lo mismo que 16 más 8 lo cual es
24 así que en efecto esto es mayor o
igual a 10 y lo puedo poner así mayor o
igual a 10 de lujo ahora si tomamos a
nuestra muestra que es 160 y lo
multiplicamos por 1
bueno 1 - 0.15 es 0.85 y esto en efecto
es mayor
o igual a 10 observa esto es 160 menos
24 lo cual es 136 y 136 es mayor o igual
a 10 de lujo
entonces se cumplen ambas condiciones y
por lo tanto podemos concluir que
nuestra distribución nuestra alan de
proporciones es aproximadamente una
distribución normal y cuál será la media
y la desviación estándar de nuestra
distribución muestral bueno en la media
de nuestra distribución muestral de las
proporciones va a ser igual a bueno
simplemente ap que como sabemos es de
0.15 está muy fácil y la desviación
estándar de nuestra distribución
muestral de las proporciones es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de
por 1 p
todo esto entre
así que esto va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 0.15 ok esto que multiplican
a 0.85 esto entre 160 y a eso le sacamos
la raíz cuadrada así que traigamos
nuestra calculadora voy a sacar la raíz
cuadrada de 0.15 x 0.85 esto entre 160
ok y esto va a ser aproximadamente bueno
si lo redondeamos en milésimas tengo que
esto es aproximadamente
0.0 28
por lo tanto tenemos una distribución
que se ve aproximadamente como una
distribución normal así que si dibujo
nuestra clásica curva de campana y la
distribución normal en tienen aquí a la
media déjame ponerla con otro color por
aquí tengo a la media que ya sabemos que
es del 15% y también sabemos que la
desviación estándar de esta distribución
muestral de proporciones es de 0.0 28
recuerda lo que queremos saber es cuál
es la probabilidad aproximada de que más
del 10% de los alumnos de nuestra
muestra reporte que ellos sufrieron
niveles extremos de estrés durante el
mes pasado así que podemos decir que por
acá tengo al 10% si por acá tengo al 10%
punto 10 entonces esencialmente lo que
estamos buscando es la probabilidad de
que nuestra muestra de 160 alumnos
obtengan una proporción para esa muestra
que sean más grande que el 10% será toda
esta área de aquí así que esta área de
aquí será la probabilidad de que nuestra
proporción sea mayor que el 10% ahora
para obtenerla traigamos de nuevo
nuestra calculadora aquí iremos al menú
de distribuciones y seleccionaremos la
opción de función de distribución normal
acumulada
ahora me pide mi límite inferior bueno
este límite inferior será un 10% punto
10 después me piden mi límite superior
el cual es 1 porque este es el valor
máximo que puede tomar una proporción
para una distribución muestral
y bueno después cuál es nuestra media
bueno es de 0.15 y cuál es nuestra
desviación estándar de nuestra
distribución muestral es aproximadamente
0.0 28 ahora apretaremos enter y si
estás respondiendo el examen a pep
debes escribirle al evaluador que
seleccionaste la función normal
cdf ahora vamos a obtener que esto es
aproximadamente el 96 por ciento así que
es aproximadamente 0.96 por lo tanto
seleccionaremos están como la opción
correcta ahora si estás en tu examen ap
debes escribir que usaste la herramienta
de normal
cdf con un el límite inferior
de 0.10
un límite superior de 1
que tu media en este caso eran de 0.15
y tu desviación estándar era de 0.0 28
sólo así los evaluadores podrán saber
cómo lo resolví xte así que espero que
esto te sirvan nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo hasta la próxima